teresa season 11 is here
one of the best season premieres in
housewives history i'm gonna say it
how do you feel about season 11. i
started to season off sad
but then i end up being really happy and
everyone kept saying i was glowing and
and i am glowing and i'm so happy so
thank you and you know i know my parents
sent
my boyfriend to me which i'm really
grateful well
you've brought him up let's get the
boyfriend talk out of the way
you look so happy what do you want the
fans to know about louie i know
you're posting a lot but you're not
talking a lot about the relationship
yeah i mean it's between you know it's
you know getting to know each other it's
between me and him
but like i am but i'm not you know i'm
not hiding him so he's out now yeah
obviously we got photographs and then we
had to be out
but i was trying to keep it on a down
low he was amazing
and you know i'm really happy so and
you know that's it will we see him on
the show at all you're gonna have to
tune in and see if you'll see him on the
show or not
okay uh i i i know all the all your fans
are already following him on social
media they're keeping an eye on him so
yeah he's on social media yes well let's
talk about the girls too because i can't
get over how grown up they are
they put a smile on my face every day
and um that's what that's what keeps me
going is my daughters
they really do and i'm you know listen
they went through a lot also
and you know getting you know some of
them needed therapy some of them
you know didn't but i was always there
hands-on
and thank god they're all we're all in a
good place they're really happy
um i'm happy joe's happy so we're all
you know we're all happy yeah it seems
like everything worked out how it was
supposed to it's not how you envisioned
it
but where you are now is where you're
supposed to be exactly
and that's how i lived life you did for
the longest time
say divorce is not an option divorce is
not what i see for myself
what was the thing that you went it's
time yeah it was
i mean him obviously you know
living in italy him you know getting
deported i mean
none of us wanted that and um yeah
how do you live a life like that and i
wasn't just gonna
you know just take my kids and move to
italy like i mean they grew up here they
want to be here
i mean maybe you never know like if my
daughter said let's go let's move to
italy
then maybe i would have did that but it
was you know my kids did not want to
move
and both for our daughters first we
really do and
you know and they see that too and they
always say mommy thank you for being so
if they thank me and they're like thank
you
for being so amazing we know that you do
everything for us
and like they they see it what did they
think of mommy and louie what do they
think of this relationship
um they like him they do like him
they're happy for me they're really
happy for me a couple weeks ago with
melania's birthday
and louie wrote her a nice message you
know
and texted her happy birthday and
everything she texted him back
like um thank you so much for coming
into my mommy's life and making her
happy
so like to me that was i was like
it's her birthday and she's talking
about me and then i started tearing up
with her
and you know like we were you know we
had a moment and
you know when we were alone i'm like
that was so sweet of you i'm like it's
your birthday and you're talking about
me so that that
really meant a lot i love how much you
light up while talking about the girls
and
and now louie it's it's so good you in
this space
especially after everything we've
watched the last decade plus
um i i know from watching the trailer
that
joe's name coming up becomes a point of
contention this season
joe judice was rashing joe gorga how
dare him say
he's got dirt on me what can you tell me
about that well exactly what you see
um i mean joe is the father of my
of my daughters he's an amazing father
um he like he's in my life and he's a
great and he did the right thing by me
and you know he has i mean everything
that happened he didn't mean it for it
to happen
he really didn't i mean so you know he
didn't want any of this to happen
um but yeah i mean the divorce was like
i think the easiest divorce
and by the whole universe so i
definitely recommend anybody getting
divorced like
think about your kids and just make it
you know listen that person is going to
be in your life the rest of your life so
just
try to like make it easy and don't even
spend all that money on lawyers
it's like just try to you know try to
split up everything
with each other and make it easy this
fight with your brother
and melissa is it as
explosive as the moment seems and as
damaging as things we've seen in the
past or is it not what we've
not up there with what we've seen in
previous seasons you're going to have to
tune in
and see how it plays out sorry
yeah i'm sorry can you tell me where
you're at with your brother and melissa
right now
um we're good we're good yeah that gives
me a hint of what we'll see and now
i i always think about my parents and
i'm never gonna disappoint them
and i'm never gonna disappoint my
children because you know
you whatever you however you are you
know
you're you're you know your your kids
are watching you
so if i always get along with my brother
because
i want my daughters to always get along
with each other
with their sisters well especially
knowing everything you've gone through
and then
i think it's important for the audience
to remember how close the loss of your
dad was
to filming this season which probably
made emotions
high yeah when i started this season and
i wasn't in a good place
i was really sad and depressed you know
it sucks
it does like you know like but you know
i guess
you know he missed my mom and he wanted
to be with my mom which i totally
understand
yeah and then i feel i really do feel in
my heart
that my parents brought louie to me
because if you before i met louie i
asked my parents to send me
an amazing person i'm like please
i call mopaba i said it's pretty nice
and i
the same street where i asked my parents
is the same street i met luia
how did you how did you meet each other
oh walking
just walking in the neighborhood like
doing on a quarantine walk you just
bumped into each other
i was at the jersey shore what kind of
rom-com are you living in teresa
i was at the jersey shore like i rented
a house for six weeks and
he rented a house he's never been at
this jersey store before he rented a
house for a week
and he was leaving the shore house and
that's and i was walking by and that's
how we met
incredible oh my gosh i love you so much
i got from when
i was with two girlfriends and my one
girlfriend like went up to him and then
that's how it all went
like yeah everything was everyone was in
the right place at the right time
right it's crazy yeah he was leaving to
come back north he was leaving the
shorehouse because he had rented it for
a week
switching gears a little bit you have
gone viral a few times over the last
couple years for i think moments just
living your everyday life that
send give people joy you seeing do
aleppo was a moment
in the car
oh i love born kisses all it takes yeah
me and melania just did a tick tock
on that on it's on her tic toc
she put it on
you made a cameo about someone's std
jessica um this is booked
by your best friend rachel
and she told me you just had sex with
your fiance's brother
that had chlamydia and the family knows
that he had it and it's starting to look
suspicious that was a whole moment
wait when i watched that i laughed for
like i couldn't stop laughing and then
the most recent one i can think of is
your instagram live with the real
housewives of salt lake city is mary
cosby
where she was talking about being
married to her step grandfather and it
seems like you were not aware that that
was
so good in these little moments
do you pay attention to the meme
conversation around you like do you see
all the people's
no is it good or bad it's everyone loves
it that's
especially that one cameo i think i
would
stay away from that family
i wish you all the best in life and um
listen it is what it is just
fix it make it better and get out of
that situation
i was just trying to help the person
like i felt bad you know i was just like
oh my god make sure you get help
i don't know or stay away from that
person yeah
i swear i laughed with my friends i
think i was it was i was at the jersey
shore and i was tired
you know i think i was drinking a lot of
tequila that night and i was just like
what did i do
now i make sure if i'm not sure about
cameo i make my friends read it and i'm
like
did i say this or not a little lesson
learned
um but then yeah then the the live with
mary cosby cracked me up because she's
talking as if you know her whole life
story talking about being married to the
man who used to be her grandfather
they're coming at me like i'm incest and
i'm gross and i'm marrying my
grandfather which sounds
ridiculous but i think well it does
sound ridiculous but i mean it
doesn't sound ridiculous it's it's my
story
and i'm not ashamed of it yeah your face
you could not hide it
no but you know what if she's happy
that's all that matters
no she's great i've talked to her too it
was just that was the kind of the first
time anyone had heard from her
too so that was it was just hysterical
all right
we got to wrap things up here anything
else you want people to know about
season 11 and what we're going to see
and what kind of i know we'll see you
date and stuff this season which is
interesting knowing where you end up
with louie
um yeah you're gonna have to tune in to
see if i really date or not
um and um yeah no i mean i want to hear
everybody's feedback you know of course
i'm sure
i'll be here you know i'll be on
instagram and i want
you know i wanted to hear what everyone
has to say
you